all those hopes you had your daughter
getting married being a grandad
seeing your nine-year-old have a 16th
birthday and 18th birthday
they just disappear
[Music]
when i first went to doctor i really had
no idea what the problem was
he gave me a blood test which is called
a psa test and every
man has this stuff called psa and they
would score normally between
one and three my father had prostate
cancer it was curable
his highest score at his peak was 12.
when i came up the results of my
prostate
test my score was 342.
prostate cancer as a cancer doesn't
really have
many side effects at first
it's something inside you your prostate
is something that's only really used
for sex and what happens is you don't
die of prostate cancer of the prostate
you die because it jumps so in my case
it's jumped to my chest
and once it jumps to another part of
your body that's the bit that kills you
it goes to your spine it goes to your
brain it goes to your lungs
and that's why it's such a terrible
killer because people don't realize
they've got it
then i embarked on a series of scans and
biopsies and other tests
and that took about two months before
the fateful day
when i sat in front of a urologist at a
hospital
and they looked at me and said i'm sorry
but you might probably only live with
two years you know he said don't think
ten if you're lucky you might live three
to four
the first thing that my wife and i did
was burst into tears
and you know it was it was something i
never absolutely expected at all
and telling your father that
statistically i'll probably be dead
before him
is not a great thing because one of the
deals when you're a dad is that you die
before your kids
so my dad was about 83 at the time
and you know to sit and tell him where i
was going wasn't a fantastic experience
for either of us
um so having him told him and my brother
then i had the really tough
gig and that was telling my kids at the
time my kids were 9 14 and 16.
and um that on the sunday following my
horrible uh reveal uh it was
uh remembrance sunday and my youngest is
in the scout so he did
the usual bit of church parade and then
we got home and i sat down and told them
and you know my 16 year old there well
basically everyone's bursting at tears
and then i made a point and i said well
she's going to play football now
and i wanted to say to them that even
though my life was
possibly going to be cut very short
right at that moment in time i was still
dead i was still able to do things
and we shouldn't get sad today and waste
today
because of what might happen tomorrow
and then when i got home
that night went to bed you start to
realize that you can't dream
we all dream ever since
you can remember you dream all those
hopes you had
your daughter getting married being a
grandad seeing your
nine-year-old have a 16th birthday and
18th birthday
they just disappear all the fun that you
have helping them move into their first
house
it's just gone so all those dreams all
those hopes to things that
life is about as far as i was concerned
have disappeared
and i probably spent about two days
just thinking poor kev you know what i
won't have
and then i spent about
a month two months thinking actually
where was kev but actually was my family
you know my wife didn't marry me so that
she could be on her own
i started thinking all the things that i
do you know without being sexist men's
jobs you know i
change the light bulbs and sort out a
leaking pipe and
get the cars serviced and cut the grass
all those things you'd have to do
you know when there's noise downstairs
at night i'll be the one that goes
downstairs and see what's going on
now she's got to do that and so
if you love someone that's quite tough
and probably four days before
chemotherapy started
i went for a run and i'm running in
tears because i remember thinking that
this might be the last time i ever run
as far as i was concerned
i had a year of treatment ahead of me of
chemotherapy radiotherapy and drugs
and then if the doctor was right and i
was gonna die in two years
then i had a year of dying so if you
think about it although i had two years
to live really my life was already over
on the following tuesday it was my first
chemotherapy session other people in
there
it was their fifth or sixth or tenth and
they looked like death
you know no one was smiling it's a
pretty awful place
and i came home and i did what i thought
people had to do after chemotherapy
and i shuffled in out of the car up my
driveway
sat in a chair my wife bought me dinner
ate that feeling miserable went to bed
chemotherapy is exactly what you think
it is you feel sick
your toenails crack your tongue goes
black your hair falls out
prostate cancer the second you get it
and start treatment takes so much away
it takes away your dreams it takes away
things like
sex you can never have sex again think
about that you know i'm a
a virile man that likes sex like most
people and it never happens again
and that's quite a tough gig you grow
man boobs you don't feel like a man
anymore
it was that defining moment i either
give up at this moment in time and
that's the end of my life
and i do the bottle of jack daniels
every night or i get up and try and have
a life still
and it was cold it was january i looked
out the window
and i said to my wife i'm going for a
run i managed three miles
it was slow it was horrible i felt sick
i got back absolutely shattered but
elated
so i ran a bit more and i ran a bit
further but never ran too far from home
i always had a backpack now with a phone
and clothes and food and
contact details in case i passed out
somewhere
and after about four weeks of
chemotherapy i went back and saw my
doctor
and i explained to him i'd entered the
brighton marathon the year before when i
was healthy
and i wanted to run it and he said he
said you can't run a marathon on
chemotherapy he said no one runs a
marathon your chemotherapy
just because no one has doesn't say no
one can and he sort of laughed and said
well if you can train for it then you
can do it
so i kept on running and it was pretty
grim have to say i remember in absolute
agony feeling like i wanted to throw up
the whole time
but i used to visualize what it was like
crossing the finish line
and i just kept going and so
on week 13 of chemo i put my foot on the
start line of the brighton marathon
with my friend jim who said he'd come
and chaperone me and we did it and i ran
the bright marathon in
four hours 36 minutes which was
about 50 minutes slower than the
previous year when i run the brighton
marathon
which was my best ever marathon time
because it goes to show you what being a
year older and chemotherapy does for you
and then that was on a sunday and on the
monday a lady i know
said look i'll get you a dodgy place in
london marathon do you want to do it i
said absolutely
so two weeks later i ran the london
marathon in four hours 26 so 12 minutes
faster than
i had two weeks before then i saw my
doctor on the tuesday and he said well
did you do the brighter marathon then i
said well actually
i showed him both medals and he kind of
fell off his chair
i said tonight so i'm going to do
something else i said what's that i said
there's this race called the uh marathon
disables
he said man subways what's that i said
well i in real simple terms it's a
marathon sunday a marathon monday a
marathon tuesday
double marathon wednesday marathon
friday and a half marathon saturday
in the sahara carrying everything on
your back going over sand dunes at 200
feet high
you're on your own you carry everything
apart from water for the week
some people say it's the toughest race
on the planet and he looked to me and
he said why would anyone want to do that
let alone someone in your situation
and i said i looked and i said well but
i want to do it and he said i'll tell
you what
if you can train for it you can do it
you know it was
a year away and i that's a long time
it's half my life
but i thought i've got to have a go and
do it so i ran loads of races in england
very slow plodding had lots of problems
with the drugs i was on they failed
ended up in hospital again somehow i
managed to get on the plane to go to
morocco
to start the mountainous cycles i got
today for
the long day i was halfway through a
double marathon
i was on my own assault flat my
shoulders were bleeding from the pack i
had massive blisters on my feet
i just didn't think i'd go on i was in
tears
then i remember the people that
sponsored me and supported me the
doctors my
friends my family a running coach i
thought if i give up now
all i'm proving is that when things get
tough you just give up
and so i kind of said you know tough up
kev and just keep going so i kept going
and finished that day and then finish
the rest of the the week
i think it came like 560th out of 1200
people
and i went to my house and my wife had
to move you into the next year then
i said what do you say well it's given
you a purpose to live that whole year
every time something was going wrong in
your life you focused on that
it was all about having chemotherapy
wasn't about trying to live two years
anymore
having chemotherapy was about trying to
get to the mouth and disciples
all the things you're doing all the
times you're ill it was all about trying
to get to that race
so i went back and i ran the 2017
marathon ensembles
i then run in iceland i ran in cambodia
in albania in jordan cross desert i went
back in 2018 and ran the mountain
cyborgs again
i'm back in 2019 around the marathon
cyborgs again
i think i'm the only person with any t4
cancer
that's ever run that race four times but
for me it became
a battle every year i do that race means
it's another year i'm alive
so april 2020 come and the marathon
disciples called off
and i trained for it and i was ready for
it and i thought
what do i do well now i've raised money
for prostate cancer uk ever since i was
diagnosed
i probably raised 250 000 pounds for
them so far
and i thought right now i bet they need
my money more than ever
so i decided to run it my back garden
and
i set off and i copied the previous
year's marathon decibels so i ran
a marathon on sunday a marathon monday a
marathon tuesday double marathon
wednesday
a marathon on friday and a half marathon
on and i back garden that's 3
600 laps in my garden i raised 33 000
pounds for charity in two weeks
it was an opportunity to put my message
out there
and a man dies every 45 minutes you
think of that you've watched half a
football match a man dies of prostate
cancer
it's the biggest killer there is no
bigger cancer
you know full stop a lot of
awareness of prostate cancer is just
realizing that if you're in the high
risk group so if you're black
or if your dad's had it or your
brother's had it or your uncle's had it
you are more likely to have it
so you need to just go to the doctor and
have a check and force the doctor to do
it because doctors don't always like
giving you a test
if you've got a partner and you're in
bed with her and she's seeing you get up
the night going for a wee
she's the one that sometimes easily goes
boy go to the doctor because if she
wants you to keep living
it's her job as much as yours to make
sure you keep going
when i was first diagnosed i was walking
to work
and i walked across trafalgar square
where they have lots of pavement artists
and it was early in the morning
and there was yesterday's pavement
artist stuff on the
chalk and there was a saying and it said
you only have two lives
and the second one starts when you
realize you only have one
and i walked past it and stopped and i
go back and read it again
and that was it you know that's when i
realized that we only have one life
so running every day is one of those
things that keeps me going
and when i have those sad thoughts i
straight away think about where i'm
going to run tomorrow
death doesn't really bother me in fact
i'm honored i've lived three and a half
years longer than i should
so i'm very lucky you know i've
i'm in our overtime bonus time and why
would you be upset when you have a bonus
so if someone told me tomorrow it was
all over of course i'd be sad about it
but i wouldn't really be upset
i can't be cross when i had three years
of amazing experiences
you